هنا في غازي عنتاب جنوبيه تركيا اجواء من
التنافس بين الاحزاب المتنافسه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه على شدها
[موسيقى]
شابه توتر غير مسبوق الثلاثاء الماضي هنا
وسط المدينه مقاطع مصوره تداولتها وسائل
اعلام محليه ونشطون في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اظهرت اعتداء نفذه انصار واعضاء
من حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض على حمله
دعائيه انتخابيه لحزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم ونتيجه الهجوم اصيبت خمسه اشخاص من
انصار حزب العداله والتنميه الشرطه
التركيه اعتقلت عضو مجلس بلديه شهيد كامل
عن حزب الشعب الجمهوري بعد ان اطلق النار
في الهواء من سلاح كان بحوزته المتحدث
باسم العداله والتنميه عمر تشيليك ادان ما
وصفه بالهجوم المسلحه الذين نفذه اعضاء من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري
واكد ان تركيا بلد امن ولا ينبغي ان يضر
الاستفزاز بتجربه تركيا الديمقراطيه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اتصل
بالمصابين هاتفيا واطلع على اوضاعهم
واطمئن على صحتهم
طبعا خصوصيتها في هذه الانتخابات فهي من
بين الولايات المتضرره من زلزال كهرمان
مرش الذي ضرب جنوبيه تركيا في السادس من
شباط الماضي
كما انها ثاني اكبر ولايه تركيه تحتضن
لاجئين لذلك عناوين الحملات الانتخابيه
هنا تركز الى جانب الوضع الاقتصادي على
ملف الاعمار وملف اللاجئين وكثيرون يدعون
الى ضروره نفذ التوتر وضبط النفس واحترام
التجربه الديمقراطيه